salut romain oil et non ça sent fort
qu'est ce tu manges du gibier non non je
mange pas à temps c'est toi qui sont
comme ça je comprends pas j'ai pris ma
douche la semaine dernière en matière
d'hygiène et de propreté il ya deux
types de personnes celles qui se passe
le visage à l'autre jardel quand vous
leur avez fait la bise et c'est qu'il
est la barre du métro en disant ah mais
sarah avancé en foutait des microbes ça
se passait très bien alors à cela on
peut leur rappeler qu'au moyen-âge
l'espérance de vie c'était une petite
trentaine d'années on peut aussi leur
reparler d'une ou deux épidémies genre
le choléra la peste mais au premier on
leur dit quoi pour les calmer
quand on leur dit que oui les germes qui
nous entourent ils peuvent être
dangereux mais qu'ils ne sont pas tous
et que l'hygiène c'est important mais
que le mieux ça peut aussi être l'ennemi
du bien un peu partout sur et à
l'intérieur de notre corps il ya des
jeunes qui forment ce qu'on appelle la
flore commensale ces bactéries à ces
micro organismes jouent des rôles
importants dans la digestion par exemple
mais il forme aussi le premier rempart
contre les microbes en protégeant notre
peau contre d'autres germes qui peuvent
nous rendre malade qu'on appelle des
germes pathogènes
donc là on parle de gentils gère mais
notez qu'ils peuvent quand même vous
rendre malade s'il décide brusquement de
déménager si un jardin qui vit dans vos
intestins élit domicile dans votre
vessie ou vos poumons par exemple est en
temps normal ces bactéries sont
absolument indispensables à votre bonne
santé et cela avait plusieurs fois par
jour ou utiliser des produits trop
agressif pour se laver
ça peut avoir deux conséquences qui font
vraiment plus de mal que de bien
un tué les gentilles bactéries qui
empêche les méchantes de rentrer et de
détruire la fine pellicule qui se trouve
à la surface de notre peau qui s'appelle
le film hydro lipidique etc a pour rôle
de l'hydrater et de la protéger
dans l'absolu ce serait même pas
nécessaire de prendre une douche tous
les jours par contre aurait quand même
penser à laver les endroits les plus
peuplés en bactéries un moyen
mnémotechnique c'est ceux qui sont
mauvais mais parce que s'ils sentent
mauvais c'est justement à cause des
bactéries qui pour le coup ci développe
en trop grand nombre
c'est comme les soirées entre potes même
s'ils sont très gentils à un moment
donné faut quand même qu'ils s'en
aillent
pour développer les bactéries apprécie
particulièrement la chaleur et
l'humidité comme celles qu'on trouve
dans des petits recoins comme les plis
ou les zones moi tu es riche en poils je
crois qu'on se comprend elles se
nourrissent de peaux mortes et de
molécules contenues dans la sueur par
exemple esquissant force et les gaz
qu'elle rejette en digérant tout ça
ouais bien l'accord ont été reloués
[ __ ] tu peux encore me faire repérer
voilà donc sachez que de temps en temps
vous pouvez vous contenter de ce qu'on
appelle une toilette de chat à ornans
qu'est ce qui t'arrive
j'essayais de faire une toilette de chat
et j'ai perdu l'équilibré bon alors
soyons clairs faire une toilette de chat
ça ne veut pas dire se laver en se
léchant les parties intimes
ça veut juste dire passer un petit coup
de gong toilettes sur les zones les plus
sales d'accord ok donc vous pouvez faire
l'impasse sur la douche de temps en
temps mais pas sur les aisselles les
organes génitaux le sillon interface y
est aussi appelée la réduc eu les pieds
les oreilles les dents et les mains à
échanger de gants de toilette à chaque
fois ce qu'en terme de moiteur et
d'humidité c'est la fête du slip pour
les bactéries vague de bons résultats il
ya d'un côté les gentils bactéries qu'il
faut pas tuer et de l'autre les
bactéries méchante et celle là ma faut
pas les yeux non plus et n'ont pas
toutes en tout cas même si c'est
écoeurant d'imaginer le nombre de
bactéries qui prolifèrent sur nos
claviers nos écrans de smartphones nos
sacs à main oui j'ai un sac à main vivre
dans un milieu aseptisé c'est le
meilleur moyen de se rendre vulnérable
aux infections
parce que pour lutter contre les
microbes notre système immunitaire il a
besoin d'y être confronté de temps en
temps comme ça il peut fourbir ses armes
les anticorps donc nettoyer chez soi ça
doit consister à faire baisser le nombre
de germes à un niveau acceptable et pas
à les faire disparaître complètement
lavé à l'eau avec un produit d'entretien
classique ça suffit même pour ce que
vous portez à votre bouche comme la
vaisselle ou tout autre chose que vous
mettez dans votre bouche
en fait il faut réserver les
désinfectants pour les endroits peu plus
de bactéries vraiment méchante c'est à
dire principalement peuplée de bactéries
fécales
c'est à dire principalement vos
toilettes ou tout autre endroit où vous
stockez votre caca alors généralement à
ce stade
viennent les questions sur la nourriture
donc je vous propose de faire un petit
point culinaire
bon on est d'accord on lave ses aliments
ni à l'eau de javel ni même au savon
d'ailleurs le plus sale généralement
dans une cuisine en tout cas le plus
susceptible d'héberger des bactéries
fécales
c'est les mains du cuisinier donc avant
de cuisiner pour cela devient l'ennemi
mais on l'a pas ce qu'on va manger cru à
l'eau claire et pour le reste la cuisson
fera son job en tuant les bactéries
petit conseil important concernant les
planches à découper les viandes et les
poissons peuvent être porteurs de germes
intestinaux c'est pas grave parce qu'ils
vont être détruits par la cuisson et ils
peuvent contaminer les légumes ou les
autres aliments que vous allez manger
cru donc pensé à utiliser deux planches
différentes
oui mais la grande question c'est est ce
qu'on peut manger ce qui est tombé par
terre et bien la réponse m
non
connaissez peut-être la règle des 5
secondes qui dit qu'on peut manger
quelque chose qui est tombé par terre si
on le ramasse en moins de 5 secondes
parce que ça pas eu le temps d'être
contaminés par des microbes en si peu de
temps
en effet il faut un temps de contact
suffisant pour arracher un nombre de
gerbes significatif à la surface où il
se trouve mais mais ça dépend surtout du
type d'aliments et de la surface sur
laquelle sa tombe
quatre secondes j'ai eu chaud si
l'aliment est mou il épouse la forme du
sol sur lequel il tombe et ça augmente
la surface de contact et si en plus il
est poreux humide collant il a d'autant
plus de chances d'arracher des bactéries
mais le plus important ça reste le sol
lui même et surtout deux choses le type
de bactérie qui s'y trouvent et leur
quantité
on l'a vu les plus méchants sont celles
contenues dans les excréments humains ou
sur des animaux et a priori il ya assez
peu de chances d'en trouver en quantités
significatives sur votre moquette
donc si vous faites tomber votre cookies
ou votre pomme chez vous ramassez et
régalez vous par contre si vous faites
tomber votre glace dans la rue ou dans
n'importe quel autre lieu public
vous prenez plus de risques dans le
doute on peut peut-être s'abstenir en
tout cas sachez là encore que s'il ya
des germes pathogènes virulents qu'on
n'a pas du tout intérêt à se coller dans
la bouche on s'immunise aussi quand on
en avale certains une étude néerlandaise
a par exemple démontré qu'un baiser
d'une dizaine de secondes avec la langue
et en parlent leur french kiss un bisou
français et bien c'est 80 millions de
bactéries échangés étaient très bons
qu'on système immunitaire donc continuer
merci docteur enfin pour le rappelle
vous oubliez pas ça marche
pour finir retenez deux choses d'abord
que la partie de votre corps avec
laquelle vous êtes le plus susceptible
de transmettre des infections passer vos
mains alors là délai régulièrement
surtout quand vous sortez des toilettes
est d'accord ok ensuite que les enfants
les personnes âgées et ceux qui
souffrent de maladies qui affaiblissent
le système immunitaire sont plus
vulnérables
donc il faut prendre plus de précautions
pareil pour les femmes enceintes parce
que leur système immunitaire est un peu
chamboulée pendant la grossesse pour
éviter qu'elles rejettent leur bébé
comme un vulgaire corps étrangers mais
aussi parce que des infections
habituellement pas bien méchante peuvent
être vraiment dangereuse pour le bébé et
la maman voilà donc est sale
évidemment c'est mauvais pour la santé
mais vouloir être trop propre c'est pas
bon non plus continuer quand même à vous
l'avez détesté c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle vidéo d'ici
là portez vous bien
posez-moi les questions vous voulez dans
les commentaires et abonnez vous pour y
ait raté à bientôt